must be so amazing what a wild adventure
i guess you you've been on in the last
little while
um can you describe to us
can you describe us how you felt and
like the balance of emotions that you
were going through
when you finally decided to speak your
truth and say that you know how you
wanted to live your life
oh yeah there was a major
fear um the biggest
the biggest supporter i have and still
have is priscilla my wife
she is just my rock and it's because she
was so
loving and so caring and so supportive
that i was able to speak it
but i i remember the first time i said
it out loud
not to priscilla but somebody else was
one of our neighbors
it took me five minutes to spit it out
because i was so
fearful of the reaction there's this
there's this internal feeling because
society has just beat it into us that
it's not okay
that's how we were raised and all the
spheres come
rushing back and find that my voice
wasn't able to just work
and eventually i i just said i'm i'm
transitioning
i remember my life was alive and of
course my neighbor was super accepting
but just
spitting it out it was like i was i had
a muzzle around my mouth i couldn't
speak
yeah and you know you talk about that
like sort of having a muzzle around your
mouth almost like walking through
a solid wall to get to the other side
and when you were able to finally say
like when it came out
and you said it for the first time was
it a relief was it like
was there still a tinge of like being
worried and scared of what was that like
yeah there was a progression so the
first person i told was our neighbor
and it was a huge relief because she
instantly said oh my gosh i'm shocked
but i absolutely love you and i support
you guys 100
so that was that was like step one and
then
it migrated to i need to tell some of my
best friends
my parents there was that whole phase
there and every time i told someone it
got a little
easier now going out in public that's
different
it's like you have to ramp up all over
again to have that courage and that
bravery because
all the fears come back differently you
don't have people that instantaneously
love and accept you the way that your
family and best friends will so now
you're faced with the real world
and you're faced with the fears that
come back how is everybody going
i'm not sure and i'm petrified i'm
terrified i'm
trembling i feel like a fraud sometimes
when i go out well not not anymore but i
used to
i wouldn't even like so that is a whole
other integration as well and
you are in a very unique situation when
it comes even when it comes to this
in that your past the way that you were
looked at
in the past your role your job as you
know
a superstar as a big macho man pro
wrestler
and i don't want to generalize so much
to the audience that watches i know lots
of different types of people watch
right but what was going through your
head when you thought
well i'm going to go out in public with
this and now all those people that saw
me
you know i'm going to be sharing my new
life with them i wonder what they're
going to think or did that
cross your mind so at that point when i
was
ready to tell my story i had this
gut feeling that can't be described any
other way than
divine to just be transparent and i knew
in my heart and in my soul that
99 of the people would be welcoming
they'd be understanding and they would
support
and i just knew that if i was
transparent and truthful
100 there was nothing to hide that i
would be accepted and we would
start changing the world and that's
exactly what happened the wwe the
wrestling community
they there's been so much outpouring of
love and support from
people that i wrestled with and worked
with with private messages
public comments uh people that i never
got a chance to work with that were
there
after i left that reached out to me and
just said how much they supported me so
that part was amazing and it's still
amazing
everything i i felt it would be
but to see it manifest the same way with
99
of the world just saying yes we totally
accept you thank you for your
transparency
that just restores my faith
that's a good community to feel a part
of that's fantastic
oh yeah absolutely and so
you know you said that you had people
that you worked with and people that you
hadn't had a chance to work with yet
uh reached out to you what what are the
sort of things that you
conversations that you had messages that
you got yeah
i saw when i saw your coming out video
it moved me to tears
it made me feel so
part of your story other people were
just saying
i didn't know who you were until you
came out and now
i i can't stop looking at your page and
following you your story is amazing
i have people from the trans community
and lgbtq community reaching out
and saying i've been afraid for so long
and your story has given me how i am
i'm no longer fearful i've had people
tell me in private messages that they
came out to their family and their
friends that they're coming out on
social media that they shared the same
fears that i that i had
one of the things i used to do is i used
to curl my nails it was the first thing
i ever did to kind of
make it so that i didn't have a chance
to pop them off and run away
so i had my acrylic nails but i would
curl them under when i went to public
and
i would see people that i thought might
not be accepting
and when my story went public one day
that
that day i just opened one and i was no
longer afraid but i shared how scared i
was
in public and i've had trans girls come
to me and to say i do the same thing
and it's so nice to know that
that's excellent the the idea of
um wwe you know when they create
characters there
they're always larger than life and sort
of historically have been
stereotypes of certain things and
there's always been talk about well how
do we represent
real people and the diversity that we
find in the world
properly and still you know maintain
that
good versus bad all the all the story
time that they do
in wrestling do you think that um
we'll be able to see more diversity of
characters and stories
uh within the wrestling ring or do you
think that that's still kind of far
off i don't think it's too far off
wrestling's come
so far since i retired and i've kind of
been peeking in
here and there and it's already changed
it used to be around my time we had a
shift
for where we had these giant really
larger-than-life characters we're
talking
over six feet tall giant bodybuilders
crazy looks to not quite
as gargantuan i guess you could say
and so what i think is happening is that
we're seeing the fans and the audience
being able to relate more and put
themselves
in those shoes and go gosh i could i
could do that someday i'm really
holding on and i'm latching on to these
stories so the short answer is i
absolutely think that you head that way
very soon and see some very
very relatable story lines and very
relatable characters
yeah we're already seeing a lot of that
i watch a lot too so we're seeing a lot
of that sony kisses there
lots of lots of different characters
that represent so i i'm
i'm on board for that i love that do you
do you ever see a moment in your future
where you might return to
the wrangler is that in your past my
wrestling days are definitely i don't
see
myself taking bumps in the ring or
anything like that i
i do we left on great terms triple h and
i had a conversation he called me
after i had left and he just basically
said hey i understand you want to go be
a father
i get it he was a dad too and he said
the door is always open so
i would never be opposed if they wanted
to do something with me
just an appearance or whatnot because i
love love the wrestling
i love being out in the arenas and
looking at the audience
it's such a rush and it's just such an
amazing opportunity so
i don't think i'd ever wrestle again but
if they offered i'd love to
just go do an appearance or say hi or do
something